a mio dio bella tutti ragazzi bevono io
che sono video sono parigi oggi siamo
tornati sui già vetri lush life è data
io perché faccio così cosa c'è una intro
che bellissima una perché ragazzi vorrei
iniziare da questo ischia boss fight
perché mi ispira al nome che senza una
boss fight su geometri da chi però vabbè
sonicmaster non è vero svetta fermi si
ma cosa come va veramente no sto male
sto male bellissimo non ho mai visto
niente di più figo lo dico ogni volta
che gioca giorno triste per ogni volta
c'è qualcosa di più figo sempre e non è
facile trovarlo c'è la cosa la cosa
bella è che ne automatico veramente la
posh spice che com è facile giocare a
super meat boy e tra l'altro quando esce
stop reso noto mentre nella chiave porca
vacca pensione pensione proprio lui devo
saltare
[Musica]
io pensavo di dover fare una cosa tipo
che do picchiarlo
che ne so 3 o ragazzi geniale bellissimo
you to this ai nudisti bellissimo belli
si può votare otto stelle invece i 59
robot challenge mostra mio amico mio
mostrami cosa vuoi farmi vedere lei on
perfetto a il robottino il robottino e
tra le cose che uso di men in geometria
quindi non sono skillato nell'usarlo
[Musica]
aiuto ho rischiato la testata va bene ce
l'ho fatta
era cortino però carino ma ci sta va
bene next ragazzi questo è difficile è
targato hard
ecco norma rae kraft e perché tutto
minecraft o mio dio no più che mai che
sembra sembra anf air mario ragazzi
uguale un fair mario porca vacca fa
anche più incavolare dal fair mario mio
dio o no ma io non ci posso credere
io non ci posso crema cosa ci devo fare
per entrare in quel buco ii e sentite
questa parte dei pidocchi chiusi per
cortesia quella quell'affare veramente
difficile da centrare ragazzi veramente
manco fosse selena gomez niente o
viceversa quando mi ci gira dall'altra
parte mamma mia mi sembra essere ubriaco
in discoteca con 8 cocktail
vai dritto ancora no mi si avvicina
torino lione
che sfiga cavolo robottino mi frega
sempre comunque ragazzi robottino è la
morte di sto gioco sono ciò che non sai
mai come prenderlo
devi capire cosa sei e che poteri ai
buon aspetto fa sta roba perfetto ho
preso pure la moneta perché sono un pro
gamer dance for play in tua madre grazie
però lo stesso mio zio ho preso cura la
moneta stato bravino c'è la sorella ma
c'era un'altra però faccio schifo quindi
va bene per 51 tentativi cinque minuti
totali
non era difficile poter essere molto
meglio ma ce l'abbiamo fatta
next l'ex cioè di swan tour vabbè i
cuori della chiesa attenzione è partito
bene c'è il coro gospel perfetto
ecco non è non è più una canzone da
chiesa che strano agio
[Musica]
porca vacca no vabbè ma mi devi
aumentare la velocità così sei pazzo
posso farcela però non è semplice sento
qui il coyote quando cerca di prendere
[Musica]
perfetto e bellissima canzone io non
solo era in geometria si trovo la mia
nuova colonna sonora della vita di cava
che non ti mettono niente per un po e
poi ti mettono la l'apocalisse subito
detto oh mio dio
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai teneri
perfetto relazione su button
non è vero quanto dura
ok ragazzi questa mappa è stata giocata
quasi 13 milioni di volte ma che che a
madonna
proviamoci ragazzi le figaro
mi devo spaventare
[Musica]
no vabbè ma stato manco che ha detto ho
capito capizzi di ho capito bene
beh beh
non è male ragazzi non è male si può
fare secondo me marco demonio mamma mia
e bellissima ragazza è bellissima e la
più bella da quando gioca geometri da
sci azzurro ciro barcala capre bella
però è bella dello giuro che bella
vabbè ma sono caduto in basso come la
mia dignità alla volta non cado e va beh
possiamo meno bassi per favore ecco non
in questo senso nel senso dei bassi del
tempo perché sono un casino ragazzi suo
livello è veramente difficile later
[Musica]
basta mi arrendo
e stato veramente difficile arrivare
fino a 72
sono contento comunque non è male il 72
di dai ragazzi di provare l'ultimo che
questo qua che vabbè che va al contrario
insomma abbastanza tranquillo
teoricamente scherzavo potrei fare
questo come ultimo no alla destra
sinistra però no ragazzi non riescono
sono stupido da parte di usare la parte
del cervello che non uso mai quindi no
ragazzi farage e con questo tentativo
qua vi saluta che finisco livello con
questo ci vediamo al prossimo video di
stavo scherzando ragazzo ok
mamma mia ho aumentato di un per cento
rispetto a prima che progressi è la mia
vita uguale a no non so fare le cose
semplici porca vacca dimette possiamo
evitare di andare dall'essere al suo
sinistra per favore
ce la faccio fino a un certo punto poi
veramente giro il monitor esistono degli
occhiali a specchio che ti fanno vedere
no poi serve la canzoncina i teletubbies
capito la cosa mi fa ancora più bestiali
re ok
o mamma mia non vedevo l'ora
no ti prego allora i figli per il culo
allegato basta basta un gioco è bello
quando dura poco il gioco è bello quando
non è un bordello la cortesia
[Musica]
ok
mamma mia quanto rischiato che sta
rischiando noti pre ok però fosse un
cambio mappa posto a posto ma ragazzi mi
sento veramente euforico senza parole
ecco esattamente quello che volevo dire
non avrei dovuto spiegarlo meglio ancora
uno stile ancora uno ada scid dash
dunque funzione seguito ecco già ci
stiamo capendo male
[Musica]
alla canzone la conosco lo finire in un
tentativo ragazzi promesso dal prossimo
l'ultimo ragazzi tanto è corto
teoricamente definirlo subito io ho
fatto un sacco di livelli tutti i corpi
di sapere nei commenti preferite tanti
livelli cortini o pochi lunghini c'è
poco in realtà alla fine e becco livello
giusto ci sta anche che un solo livello
sia un video dipende fatemi sapere
questa cosa ragazzi sono molto curioso e
soprattutto fatemi sapere chi deve
insultare con l'importante o mio dio
e vabbè non ci ha promesso di fare su
perso la casa e muoio spero che il video
vi sia piaciuto
ci vediamo a un prossimo video con fi j
su geometri dash po difficile pero bello
bello bello asfaltati di sapere se
preferite livelli nick orti o un po più
lunghi pro di meno però c'è il rischio
che non finisca
però c'è il rischio che possa perdere un
embolo sei un embolo spero che mi sei
piaciuto ragazzi schiacciate il tasto
iscriviti e schiacciata la campanella
che così che arrivano le notifiche per
tutti i video e noi come sempre ci
vediamo allora belle ragazze
[Musica]